ont été vendus.
Certains craignent qu'un
des plus vieux quartiers chinois
en Amérique du Nord
ne disparaisse.
Mélissa François.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le quartier chinois
de Montréal a perdu de
sa vitalité, pourtant il recèle
des commerces à découvrir et
des bâtiments historiques.
JONATHAN CHA, Groupe de travail
quartier chinois de Montréal
- Le dernier étage de
ces batiments-là et on le voit
avec les enseignes chinoises,
sont souvent des bâtiments qui
sont abrités par
des associations claniques, donc
des étages qui sont réservés
à une famille, à une grande
famille, que ce soit les Wong,
les Lee, par exemple, donc, ils
sont propriétaires souvent
depuis des générations.
♪ ♪ ♪
Un des édifices qui caractérise
le quartier c'est celui-ci,
conçu en 1826. À l'époque,
il abritait une école, la
British and Canadian School.
Aujourd'hui, il est occupé
par le fabricant de biscuits
orientaux et de nouilles Wings
en activité depuis plus
de 100 ans. L'immeuble a été
vendu en mars.
- On parle d'un bâtiment qui
a 200 ans d'histoire, et à côté
de lui parmi les maisons
les plus anciennes du quartier,
donc la moitié des bâtiments
que vous voyez ont déjà été
achetés par des développeurs
qui souhaient en faire un grand
projet immobilier.
- La vente oblige le Service
à la famille chinoise
de Montréal a quitter le local
qu'il occupait depuis plus
de 30 ans pour s'établir
ailleurs dans le quartier. Bien
des membres de la communauté
craignent que le développement
commercial nuise à l'héritage
culturel du quartier chinois.
XIXI LEE, d.g. Service à la
famille chinoise, Grand Mtl.
- Ça nous inquiète beaucoup
parce que c'est un milieu de vie
pour les Chinois, surtout
pour les aînés qui ne parlent ni
français ni anglais. C'est
la famille ici.
- On ne sait pas encore
précisément ce qu'il adviendra
du site vendu. Le développeur
immobilier Hillpark Capital
assure
- Entre-temps, Québec et
la Ville de Montréal lancent
un comité de travail afin
de trouver des moyens
de préserver l'identité
du quartier chinois.
VALERIE PLANTE, mairesse de
Montréal
- Tout sera examiné pour encore
une fois, oui, le quartier
change et se développe, mais
il ne faut pas perdre l'âme.
Il en a déjà perdu une bonne
partie selon Héritage Montréal.
TAIKA BAILLARGEON, dir.-adjointe
politiques, Héritage Montréal
- Il y a eu de nouvelles
construction qui se sont faites
sans nécessairement que soit...
qu'il y ait eu une volonté
de préservation puis de
protection et ça a mis à mal
le quartier puis bon an mal an,
il y a eu des pertes incroyables
puis là on se rend compte que...
il ne restera plus rien s'il n'y
a pas un effort qui est fait.
- Le Groupe de travail sur
le Quartier chinois de Montréal
espère que les actions viendront
rapidement, voire d'ici la fin
du mois de juin, car le secteur
est très convoité.
Une reconnaissance patrimoniale
aiderait à la préservation
du quartier et à mieux contrôler
son développement.
Ici Mélissa Fra